what the hell I don't want it is started
how's it going bros amazed welcome back
to this nightmare of a game alright
what see here alright Ruben is missing
see stever see Steve Oh Steve will do as
Ruben Ruben I don't like you I don't
like how he looks at me it makes me
uncomfortable
see I don't understand how I'm gonna do
this without running out of the power
that's Oh God
alright alright he's here [ __ ] you -
Ruben he just wants to creep up on me
like hey why are you down cats now tell
me I want to know what you're doing pets
I don't like him oh where did he go now
Oh God Ruben is still out there
No so all sat and Ruben is out and Steve
is there where's Ruben where that [ __ ]
is Ruben so for me to make it I can't
waste more power
there's Ruben that makes me feel good
was I still there everyone is so we can
celebrate we can enjoy our time here
together everything is awesome
alright Steve still learn also still
there where the [ __ ] is row bed where
the [ __ ] is roben you see there oh yeah
he's in the hole maybe you just want to
get a snack you know I can't click the
light I can't click them what the [ __ ]
what is up with that
did I use it too much no oh I'm dead
Oh God Oh God what the [ __ ] Steve is on
a meth
ah god I can never do it ah I just can
never do it it seems random to what's
gonna help god damn it Steve stat and
Reubens out Reubens out that's cool
I like that marshmallow cupcake by the
way it's wonderful even that's creepy
actually nevermind okay now he is there
okay that's fine you can snow god oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh god don't like
it when he does that
oh there yes my job sucks
can we just talk about this for the
second res alright so how much would you
if you had to work at this place how
much would you have to earn per day to
be able to do it I wouldn't do it for
all the money in the world then I don't
know I'm just saying [ __ ] this place
what was that I heard something no oh he
moved [ __ ] moved they assisting the
clock get out of the closet Reuben it's
late just go to sleep
Oh God
oh [ __ ] he's there oh my god he's in the
whole corner Oh God a wall stays out oh
god what did he do it
you're ugly just deal with it you she's
not photogenic okay how about that
Reuben is still there I don't get it man
I just don't get it
Oh oh [ __ ] you and your [ __ ] couch
stop it Oh
what does that happen why does that bad
this one works fine men fit Danny Bolen
they're all they're fantastic
oh I heard something they both move at
the same time oh god they're all awake
now
come on it was so peaceful just go back
to sleep guys just go back to sleep
it's gonna be great where's the [ __ ]
chicken
where's the [ __ ] chicken I was
in here
Roo buddy's in there okay we're good we
good can't waste too much battery though
cuz then I'll I don't wanna die
Oh God okay he's there chicken is still
there
we're all good all good in the hood oh
god where's your uber where is your bait
Oh God don't be my face
Robert stay out of my town man oh god I
hate him everybody's like a fangirl that
just wants to suck on your nips and it's
just awkward cuz you're like no I don't
want it just me okay well you know he's
still out there no it's that Rupert or
is there someone else
now he's back there now where did Rubik
go then oh there it is right it's so
hard to see him but I think is there
yeah he's there oh god oh god what does
that mean oh god what does that mean
what does that me I got him out of usage
come on hey well many
I understand I don't understand why he
just locks up like that oh great she's
right [ __ ] there
no not allowed in my town [ __ ]
not allowed
no she's still outside there we go
almost took all my battery one more hour
come on come on whoa Oh God there he is
and there she is
okay - wait it's almost 6:00 come on
yeah oh my god you have no idea how good
that feels it's so hard and you have to
restart ten minutes this game is [ __ ]
ultimate rage game of ball slaps in the
face it Gary's looking at me like what
the [ __ ] is he doing right now
I bet you're doing that - oh god it's a
[ __ ] again alright thanks
oh great big guy Terry Oh alsace out
much of your time start getting a ryokan
idea if you have to think it caught and
want to avoid getting stuff ready to try
playing dead you know thanks I'll try
that [ __ ] you have any useful tips I
bet I just have to be so focused in this
game I can't talk
I just can't also there's a [ __ ] there
you go that's all I got for you just you
and me Oh sir
I love that was a scientist by the way
they're [ __ ] hard I wonder where she
got them probably Victoria's Secrets I
don't know where else you can get that
fab no acai you're not allowed to play
with me you [ __ ] you snitch mate oh
sorry
you stay the [ __ ] out sail out get a
life also we're never gonna be together
I don't care how fab you are I just
don't care halfway there bros come on
it's more like challenged in a horror
game at this point
oh great yeah you just don't run don't
yell don't scream don't poop on floor
stay close to mommy
I love the rules I didn't notice until
that that's hilarious oh god he's out I
can't handle two retards at the same
time I'm sorry but I can't
where's the chicken oh god oh god oh god
no no no no no no no okay where's the
other guy
where is he
I can't the new iPad from Steve Jobs
with the pho great they're both [ __ ]
out so great
fantastic fan-fucking-tastic
they're both outside Oh God
nope I oh there is okay booking up in
this oh thank god one more hour one more
hour one hour oh god oh god oh god
they're yes
where's chicken man where s is that fat
[ __ ] is eating [ __ ] me hard man don't
do it especially a lot by those Oh God
Oh God [ __ ] you where's the chicken
where's alsa oh that was ace okay there
she is that [ __ ] oh god oh god
boss I don't play games with me all sigh
I was really out of battery oh god oh
god no I did I did I did I did I so
[ __ ] dead
now a stock house well acceptable all
right race that's all the time I had for
today oh I didn't like if you enjoyed
this episode and if you wanted me to
play more hits a scratch come a birthday
thanks for having me today bros i I'm so
I'll calm down next one al the won't be
late I promise that's all for me stay
awesome bros